>>
UNMASKING
DR. FAUCI DEFENDS THE NEW CDC
GUIDELINES FOR VACCINE.
SPEAK OF THE FACT IS THAT THERE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE INDIVIDUAL
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ONE HAS AN
WITH YOU OTHERS.
IF YOU GET INFECTED, EVEN IF YOU
ARE WITHOUT SYMPTOMS, YOU VERY
WELL MAY INFECT ANOTHER PERSON
WHO MAY BE VULNERABLE, WHO MAKE
IT SERIOUSLY ILL.
IN ESSENCE, YOU ARE ENCROACHING
ON THEIR INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS.
>> THAT SAYS IT "OUTNUMBERED"
AND ON EMILY COMPAGNO.
HERE’S MY KOS KAYLEIGH
McENANY, HOST OF "KENNEDY,"
KENNEDY, TOMI LAHREN, AND IN THE
SEAT, LAWRENCE JONES.
THE MAYOR OF D.C. IS KICKING OFF
THE HYPOCRISY PARADE AS DEMOCRAT
WOULD SEEM MASSLESS AT A WEDDING
AFTER REINSTATING THE MASS
MANDATE.
LORI LIGHTFOOT ALSO SEEN
MASSLESS RUBBING ELBOWS WITH
CELEBRITIES AT LOLLAPALOOZA.
THIS AS SHE’S FACING CRITICISM
WITH ALLOWING THAT IS ABOUT HER
MUSIC FESTIVAL AT ALL.
AND THEN THERE’S FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS DEFYING CDC
GUIDANCE FOR HER’S UPCOMING 60TH
BIRTHDAY BASH INVITING 500
GUESTS TO HIS MARTHA’S
VINEYARD’S MANSION.
COVACATIONS ARE RISING AND
WORKING ON THE WAY.
NANCY PELOSI, HOOTERS REINSTATED
THE MASS MANDATE IN THE HOUSE IS
DIRECTING CAPITOL POLICE TO
ARREST THOSE WHO REFUSE TO WEAR
ONE.
SHE SEEMED TO FLOUT HER OWN
RULES JUST DAYS LATER.
>> 20 20 OFF OUR MASKS CUSHION W
IS ALLOWED?
>> LAWRENCE, WELCOME BACK TO THE
SHOW.
THIS PATTERN IS EXHAUSTING.
WE ARE NOW 17 MONTHS INTO WHAT
HAS BEEN A PANDEMIC IN THESE
FLUCTUATIONS OF MASK MANDATES
AND NOT WITH THESE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS CONTINUING TO BEHAVE
LIKE THIS.
TO FLOUT THEIR OWN MANDATES THAT
THEY SENT IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
>> Lawrence: IT’S GREAT TO BE
HERE WITH ALL OF YOU LADIES.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THESE
ELECTIVE OFFICIALS LIVING THEIR
LIVES.
THAT IS WHAT THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS ARE SAYING RIGHT NOW.
LET US LIVE OUR LIVES.
IT IS OVER A YEAR NOW AND LET’S
GET BACK TO SOME NORMALITY.
THE PROBLEM IS, THEY’VE BEEN
TELLING THE PUBLIC THEY CANNOT
DO THAT.
AT FIRST, I THOUGHT THE MASK AND
ALL OF THESE MEASURES WERE A
SECURITY BLANKET.
COVID DID BREAK A LOT OF PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY MENTALLY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE MENTALLY
RECOVERING FROM THAT.
I THOUGHT WAS THAT MEASURE THAT
WE SHOULD JUDGE HIM BY.
BUT THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IN ANY
OF THIS NONSENSE BECAUSE WE KNOW
FOR FACT NOW THAT THE RULES THEY
ARE REPLACING FOR OTHERS, THEY
ARE NOT FOLLOWING THEM
THEMSELVES.
I WOULD CAUTION OUR LEADERS TO
LOOK AROUND THE WORLD.
LOOK AT PLACES LIKE FRANCE WHERE
THERE IS MASSIVE PROTESTS GOING
ON WHERE PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT
THEY REJECT WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
IS DOING AND THEY’RE SICK OF IT.
IT IS ONLY A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE THOSE PROTESTS COME TO
THE UNITED STATES.
WE SAW THE SAME THING WITH CUBA.
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT FREEDOM
AND THEY REJECTED SOCIALISM AND
THEY DO NOT LIKE THE OUTCOMES OF
THAT.
AMERICANS SHOULD BE AWARE OF
THIS AS WELL AS OUR LEADERS.
THERE IS A HIDDEN AGENDA IN
THIS.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO RELEASE A
CONTROL.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER WAY FOR
GOVERNMENT TO BECOME DADDY
AGAIN.
WE KNOW WHERE THIS ENDS AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
I DO NOT SEE A SHIFT FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ALSO WENT TO SOME OF THESE
MEASURES TO CONTINUE THE
ELECTION AND THE WAY IT WAS IN
THE PAST YEAR.
SOME OF THE SAFETY MEASURES WERE
PUT IN PLACE.
THEY ARE ABLE TO PASS HR ONE IF
THEY SAY, "LOOK, WE ARE A
PANDEMIC TYPE ENVIRONMENT SO WE
NEED MORE DRIVE-THROUGH VOTING,
WE NEED MORE MAILING VOTE IN."
AT THE END OF THE DAY, AS MUCH
AS I WANT TO SAY THEY HAVE GOLD
WILL, THERE’S ALWAYS AN END GOAL
WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Kayleigh: AT CERTAIN RIGHTS
AND LIBERTIES BECOME CONSTRICTED
AND PEOPLE WERE WILLING TO DO SO
FOR THE RIGHT OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
THAT HAS BEEN WASHED AWAY BY
THIS CONFUSING MIXED MESSAGING
AND THE HYPOCRISY ON THESE
LEADERS.
THEY FAILED TO DEMONSTRATE THE
IMPORTANCE EVEN AS A DELTA
VARIANT IS WORMING ITS WAY IN
THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO GO ON FROM
THESE PEOPLE SO WHY SHOULD ANY
OF COMPLIANCE?
>> Kennedy: THEY SHOULD BE
LOOKING TO THE POLITICIANS THAT
THEY RIGHT NOW ALMOST COMPLETELY
DISTRUST.
THE ACTORS BETRAYED THEIR
BELIEFS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THE VIRUS IS
NOT DEADLY OR IT IS VERY
POLITICAL AND IS NOT GOING TO
INFECT DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE FOR THEIR OWN PERSONAL
LIVES AND WHO THEY GO OUT AND
SAY AND HOBNOB WITH, THOSE OF
THE STANDARDS WE SHOULD HAVE.
IT IS MUCH BETTER FOR
POLITICIANS TO SAY, "YOU HAVE TO
BE THE ONE IN CHARGE OF YOUR OWN
DECISIONS."
INSTEAD OF THESE BLANKET
MANDATES THAT END UP HURTING THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED THE MOST LIBERTY
AND THE MOST OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
NOW.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
HAMSTRUNG BY THIS HYPOCRISY.
WHATEVER THEY ARE DOING, THAT IS
THE NEW UNIFORM SET OF
STANDARDS.
WE CAN GO TO WEDDINGS, WE CAN GO
TO CONCERTS, WE CAN HAVE
PARTIES, WE CAN BE UNMASKED
BECAUSE THEY DID.
THEY’RE THE ONES WITH THE DEBT
UNDER THE ONES WITH THE CONTROL.
>> Emily: LEAD BY EXAMPLE.
AND TO KENNEDY’S POINT, WE ARE
SEEING IS OTHERWISE.
NOT ONLY FOR FAILING TO COMPLY
WITH IT, BUT THERE’S A MASSIVE
MASSIVE -- SPEAKER PELOSI
THREATENING POLICE ON HER FELLOW
CONGRESSMEN IF THEY FAIL TO WEAR
A MASK OF ACCIDENT.
>> Tomi: YOU CAN LOOT A TARGET
OR A FOOTLOCKER, HE COULD HAVE
MATHS SHOPLIFTING THE DEMOCRATS
BUT IF YOU DON’T WEAR YOUR MASK,
OR IT I CALL IT FROM YOUR TO
NEIGHBOR, NANCY PELOSI’S GONNA
COME AFTER YOU.
THAT IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
AT THIS POINT.
WE WERE TOLD THAT WE DO FLATTEN
THE CURVE.
IF WE EVER FELL FOR THAT AGAIN,
WE ARE AND WE ARE SHEEP.
WE DID NOT KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON AND WE DID NOT KNOW HOW TO
CONTROL HIS PANDEMIC.
IT HAS BEEN OVER A YEAR AND A
HALF WE’VE ACCEPTED THAT COVERT
IS NOT GOOD TO BE ERADICATED
ANYTIME SOON.
WITH TO BE SAFE, IF POSSIBLE,
PROTECT MOST VULNERABLE, BUT WE
HAVE TO PUT LIVE OUR LIVES.
LET’S DEMOCRAT TOWARD US AND
THESE DICTATORS, ONCE THEY CAN C
AND GIVE UP OUR RIGHTS, BUT
YOU WON’T GET THEM BACK.
THE DANGLING CARROT IN FRONT OF
YOUR FACE.
FIRST IT WAS IF YOU CAN FAX
ANYTHING YOU DON’T HAVE TO WEAR
A MASK.
AND THEY TOOK OUT.
ANOTHER SAYING THAT EVEN IF YOU
WERE VACCINATED AND YOU HAVE TO
WEAR A MASK.
AMERICANS ARE WONDERING WHAT IS
NEXT.
THERE’S A LOT OF BUSINESS OWNERS
CLUTCHING HER TEETH VERY
CONCERNED THAT WE’RE GOING TO
HAVE MORE LOCKDOWNS, MORE
SHUTDOWNS THERE’S GOING TO FLEE
TO PORT TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT OF
PEOPLE COLLECTING MONEY AND NOT
GETTING THEM TO COLLECT STOMACH
RETURNED TO WORK.
LAWRENCE IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE WEAPONIZING THIS AND THEY
WEAPONIZE THAT EVERY SINGLE
TIME.
DID I SET ON THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
>> Emily: IT IS REALLY
DIFFICULT TO GET A FACT.
WE HEARD IN THE AND TRUE,
DR. FAUCI SAYING THAT FAILING TO
WEAR A MASK IS, "ENCROACHING ON
OTHERS INDIVIDUAL RATES."
>> Kayleigh: HE MIGHT NOT KNOW
WHAT INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS ARE.
I COULD SHARE THEM WITH THAT.
FIRST AMENDMENT.
RIGHT TO WORK, CHURCH, WORSHIP,
THESE ARE YOUR INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS.
NOT ANYONE ELSE’S INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS INFRINGED UPON BECAUSE
YOU AREN’T WEARING A MASK.
MAYBE HE HAS TO STUDY THAT.
THAT BEING SAID, LET ME JUST
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT THIS IS
NOT HER FIRST OFFENSE AT
HYPOCRISY.
SHE TOOK THE TRAIN TO DELAWARE
OR PLAIN, TO GO TO ABIDE IN
VICTORY PARTY DESPITE HER OWN WA
THIS IS MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT
SECOND DEFENSE.
WHEN OTHERS COULDN’T GO, SHE
SAID ON THE PUBLIC FACE OF THE
CITY.
THAT IS THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM.
THE CITY WHEN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC, YOU CANNOT GO TO
CHURCH, YOUR KIDS CANNOT GO TO
SCHOOL, MUST WEAR A MASK BUT I
WILL GO TO CALIFORNIA.
I WILL GO TO MY LAVISH MARTHA’S
VINEYARD, BUT YOU DO NOT GET TO.
WHEREBY SHE DOES NOT APPLY TO
ME.
WHATEVER THERE WAS A TRUMP
RALLY, IT WAS A SUPER-SPREADER
EVENT.
A THOUSAND HELPFUL OFFICIALS
CAME UP AND SAY THAT WE DO NOT
CONDEMN THESE GATHERINGS IS
REALLY FOR COVID-19 TRANSITIONS.
ONE STANDARD FOR A TRUMP RALLY
ONE FOR BLM RALLY.
AMERICAN SEE THE HYPOCRISY.
>> Emily: FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF, WE HAVE BEEN SEEING THIS
PATTERN OF HYPOCRISY.
IT IS EXHAUSTING AND IT HAS